there are days that define your story
beyond your life like the day they
arrived I'm Colonel GT Webb of Romney
intelligence pack your bags
we're at the top of everyone's list when
it comes to translations I already won
what do you want where are you from
you'll be reporting to me but you'll be
working with him when you're in the
shell that's what they call in a UFO
who's being carted off in the medevac
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do it's what is alive you'll
see soon enough every 18 hours a door
opens up that's where we go in
yeah that has happened
we live in the day I arrived
you need to see me say now that's a
proper introduction have landed around
the world this is one of 12 we're never
gonna be able to speak their words go
through these figure something out
it's their language
we need to make sure that they
understand the difference between a
weapon and a tool language is messy and
sometimes one can be both
are you dreaming in their language it's
possible they're prodding us to fight
among ourselves this is just a way to
force us to work together for once it's
more complicated than how is it more
complicated Russia just executed one of
their own to keep their secrets about 21
hours at home base not level more so how
do we clarify their intentions I go back
in well does this feel worse
you